[inaudible] here with Robert Krulwich
today on radio lab, an hour on the self,
how it is the debt of a trillion
chattering neurons in your brain or as the
greatest illusion of all
that you are. One thing,
one self to extend this a little
bit. Uh, another step chat.
Well we spent the whole time talking
about what it is to be a one or where is
our self.
There are times when you learn that the
self is not got a Berlin Wall around it.
We are porous. Our borders
are full of the leaks.
Robert Sapolsky is a biologist. He
studies baboons in, in East Africa.
He wrote an essay which I read and
the essay is the story of his dad.
Robert has a dad like we all do. This.
Dad suffered from a condition
that resembles Alzheimer's,
so his father was forgetting things,
what decade it was, where he was,
but he was also beginning
to melt into the sun.
The Dad was beginning to tell
stories that really the sons stories,
there's all kinds of things.
Things like I had moved from New York to
the bay area at that point and suddenly
his stories of his immigration changed
from when we left Europe and came to
Ellis island to when we left Europe and
entered the United States to the San
Francisco Bay,
including his describing the first
side of the Golden Gate Bridge,
golden gate bridge, which
was built decades after he
came to the United States.
Completely confabulated but San
Diego was involved to San Diego.
I was in San Diego for a period and he
suddenly had spent long periods of time
in San Diego, in the
navy, in World War II,
so that he was able to have the
same opinion and share the same,
just kind of the edges of
him spilling over into me.
Did that make you feel a
little claustrophobic or a
little claustrophobic and
being a good scientist? Of course.
What I did instantly was try to label it
and come up with diagnostic categories
and pathologize it and sort of keep it
at a safe distance and it was all fairly
unnerving.
And what this particular essay was about
that I had written was amid all of that
sort of confident pathologizing it was
only after he died that I suddenly found
myself doing the same in return.
[inaudible]
let me read you some of what Robert
Suppose you wrote about this experience.
It started manageably enough how you
arrange the utensils is heated from a
favorite Yiddish tonight
is throughout the day.
Soon I had forsaken wearing my blue
flannel shirts in order to wear the blue
sweater ones. Oh he is.
I took a shirt at his,
a flannel shirt and light back before
global warming would always wear flannel
shirts and for awhile I had to wear his
flannel shirt instead or he had heart
disease and the little
bottles of Nitroglycerin all
over the house and there was
this period where in the
immediate aftermath of his dying,
I took a bottle of some nitroglycerine
back with me and found I had to keep it
with me physically all the time.
Now you didn't have heart trouble.
I had no heart trouble
and I was a 30 year old.
You're walking around with this
Nitroglycerin, like it's your blankie,
like you don't want to give it up. No.
On some level I needed to
have nitroglycerin with me
handy in case like I had
one of his angina attacks
[inaudible]
he writes, I would make love to my wife,
workout in the gym, attend the lecture,
and always the bottle would be nearby
on a nightstand, in a sweat
jacket, pocket of midnight papers.
There was a day when I
briefly misplaced it,
it everything stopped
for an anxious search.
It was not that I'd lost a holy relic
of his suffering and object to show my
children someday to teach them about a
man they hadn't known. This was urgent.
I felt vulnerable.
You're very hard to articulate.
But during that period also,
I had a large class I was doing on
the last day of a lecture. I found,
I gave this weird lecture where
essentially I was talking to them like an
octogenarian.
You don't believe it now because you're
20 you're going to get tired and you're
going to get tired.
You're gonna get tired and it's just
gonna get harder and harder just from the
tired old 30 year old. Yeah, exactly.
I was talking to them as an 80
year old and talking to them.
You wake up to that notion in the
middle of it. Did you say anything? Hey,
what am I doing? I didn't know just
how long they can't wait till evening.
Trying to figure out the hell was that
about instead of telling them about
what's going to be on the final telling
them you should be happy all your mother
and the second call me
as long as you're at it,
it could hurt you to
call now. And then, um,
and when you had finished the lecture to
the kids who had been speaking through
the voice of your dad,
how did you unwind this connection
or did it just fade away? Um,
interestingly I actually gave that lecture
wearing his shirt on and this was a
very whole challenged period with the
bottle of Nitroglycerin in my pocket cause
I had it in my pocket at all times.
And it was that night that I was able to
put away the bottle and having worn the
shirts sense and on some level
I was saying goodbye for him.
Um, and particularly appropriately
to, you know, an auditorium,
a wash in 520 year olds with
their world ahead of him and
Sudu saying goodbye for him
a year later that time
has begun to make sense.
I feel sure that what I went
through need not merit a diagnosis.
It's a measure of my training
as a scientist that I saw
pathology there wasn't
there and essentially with that whole
period was about, it was a learning.
It is, you know, a perfectly normal,
non pathological state to feel at times
of extreme emotional challenge that
interconnected with another person.
That in some ways the boundaries slip a
little bit. It can only come as an echo.
A hint in our armored individuated
world did a bit of confusion as to ego.
Boundaries can be an act of health,
of Hamas and love.
It can be a whisper of what it feels
like to be swaddled and cut nudity.
It is a lesson.
I mean our ever expanding array of
scientific labels on the risks of over
pathologizing most of all. It is a
lesson that it wouldn't be so bad.
In fact,
it would even be a point of pride if in
the end someone mistakes you for him.
Mike, just post good questions.
Is, did you ever, um,
say to your dad when he was ill, um,
you didn't come to San Francisco. Did
you ever like correct him? Not a chance.
Robert Sapolsky is a biologist at
Stanford University in California.
He's written several
collections of essays,
but the one we're quoting here is
from the trouble with testosterone.
That's where you find
the story of his dad.
For more information on that or
anything else you heard tonight,
check our website, radiolab.org
while you're there.
Communicate with US radio
lab@wnyc.org is the address chat here.
Robert and I are signing off now,
but we will catch you next time.